okay
hello hello hello
oh yeah
right there
good stuff
this work I think so
hello
what's up
what's up angel dragonlord gfg
Stan yo-yo
I have the camera on today here it is
what you guys wanted
oh that's good dragon
I tried
okay
this is gonna be super [ __ ]
howdy
I'm eating yellow cheese
that's that's a comment right there
that's that's a comment
if I've ever heard a comment oops
it's not ready but here we are
what would a no NPC run of Eldon ring
look like
um just to complete no context
Eldon ring
that's that's it
just don't talk to anybody well and you
can't level because you have to talk to
melna so
it sounds kind of insane
you know
that seems kind of silly
I'm eating blue cheese you guys like
cheese
I don't really eat cheese like just off
the rip
you know it's got to go on something you
know
I I don't just eat cheese seems kind of
weird
I never do that
that seems gross
a little bit
maybe I'm weird
I twisted
okay so that's different that's like
melted cheese I'm talking like you take
a piece of yellow Velveeta and just eat
it
I've never done that well I'm sure I
have but I didn't like it
I Jam
um
let's go acquies
[Music]
let's go
thanks for becoming a tarnished and
being the first member of the day let's
go baby
whew
we're only 23 members away from our fun
wheel of level run by the way chat
somebody came up with that idea
yesterday it was red
something I can't remember the full name
I'm sorry but uh
he had the idea of
we do a play through where we spin a
wheel for every level and whatever it
lands on we have to level that
I one I really wonder what that would
end up being like
I'm gonna change your font chat
I don't like it
as the font
you guys tell me what you like
because you're the chat let's try this
is this better
whenever you you know whenever you see
it
yeah red potatoes that's right yep that
is a genius idea that I've never thought
of or seen before so that could be
really fun so if we get 23 which is this
number right here
23 more to get to 100 then we'll do that
run and then we'll come up with
something else on another goal
what have you learned about being a maid
since doing this uh I'm glad
that I uh
did a bunch of Sword runs
because I know all the bosses moves up
close and when I dodge them
it just makes everything easier to dodge
since I like let's say I started as a
mage
I wouldn't really know because I'm
always just trying to back up you know
I I've learned this is pretty easy it's
a lot easier than just like a giant
sword
oh yeah it's way smaller
uh I can make it bigger
why is it that small it's weird
let's try this
increase the size
uh now I ask if you notice the black
assassin knives and melania's knife is
similar
but melanos is somehow modified to be
good
it might be a renegade assassin
well
think about it in a different way
what if all the black knife assassins
were at one point like Melina
until all the [ __ ] went down and now
they're the Black Knight assassins
because all of them are women and all of
them are Newman just like Queen America
and I would say queen America
and radagon
are pretty much dead like do you guys
get that get that weird feeling with
them like I I see radagon when we fight
him which is technically Queen America
I see him as like
being a puppet that the greater will is
using
and he's not like really fighting us
does that make sense
that's how I see it
[Music]
right that's kind of what I'm saying
angel
that's that's how I see it
well now is the chat too big
takes a quarter of my 4K screen way too
big
what
why'd you just throw out your 4K screen
real quick there bro
you you trying to flex huh
I mean I can make it a little smaller
oh God
oh
God
oh boy
oh boy
Twisted with the five gifted members
were already at 82.
oh Father nope I gotta skip these
I don't know why it does that
Twisted thank you for getting it started
for today I appreciate it you've gifted
a lot of members yesterday too bro thank
you very much
um
that looks fine on my 65 inch flat
screen TV okay bro
so the alerts work but for whatever
reason stream elements is like yeah
those people renewed their sub as well
even though they didn't they just got
gifted
but Twisted I really really appreciate
the gifted thank you very much
they so they do work stand the other
part of it is nothing I can do nothing
about
I literally can't
but if you got a gifted member from
Twisted make sure to say thank you
let's go
okay
let's listen to Ronnie's beautiful voice
oh
again we cross paths thank you thank you
thank you
now we're only 17 away huge but please
with me to see torrent Hale and Hearty
tarnished
what business has thou here I have no
memory of inconvenient invitation Harry
Potter baby
chat I have a question
with this
is there any way to have an option that
isn't no particular reason
this is already kind of a lore stream
but I'm just asking questions man you
guys told me to ask questions and if it
was a stupid question I told you to shut
me tell me to shut the [ __ ] up and that
that'd be fine
you can you can tell me that if it's a
dumb question
Bach cosplay
sounds really hard but it could be done
yes how
cause I could leave this conversation go
do that and come back and and have a
reason
if you bring the black knife print to
Roger
the black knife print
why why am I not remembering what that
is
if you do Roger's Quest but too late now
I can leave
this this conversation will never happen
if I just walk away right now
Roger will ask you to go there there's
an option about the black knife Knight
okay we're gonna walk away
bye never happen in her brain
let me go to the Round Table
something with FIA
the black knife print that FIA gives me
is that what it's called
the knife
really how do you all remember this [ __ ]
how
let's get a hug it's great Champion cold
what up murals I am fear hi Lewis we're
good bro how about you
black knife catacombs great
[Music]
would you allow
Ed some of your Lively figure I wish
someone asked me for a random hug doing
so will grant me the warmth
and you I am sure you can skip this by
getting a nice print right away it's
blessing
with you asked for it just
wait you can ask Thea about where the
black knife catacombs are are you guys
serious
I'm thinking Laura Wise why would she
know that just for the the print
oh my thanks
I'm gonna get a hug
I love hugs
you get the map from her
huh
you are she gives good hugs she felt
light up inside you what's up
ask Roger about the night then speak
with FIA again come back
should you require another so now I go
talk to Roger
I'm just a little bit closer
understanding the whole plot which is
nice that's that's good Mira
she's a bedtime companion
guys I I take that as she's kind of a
hoe
that that's it sounds like a gracious
way to say I sleep around
am I wrong for thinking that
because I don't know how you sleep with
Godwin he's a giant weird fish monster
always good to see you safe
so
what do you need we think
about the corpse under Stormville the
misshapen corpse under stormvale that is
a sacred relic of the black knives plot
as that famed night of assassination is
known it happened during the golden age
of the Earth tree long before the
shattering of the Eldon ring someone
stole a fragment of the Rune of Death
From malacath the Black Blade and on a
bitter night murdered Godwin the golden
that was the first recorded death of a
demigod in all history and it became the
catalyst soon the Elden ring was smashed
and thus sprang forth the war known as
the shattering I once wished to become a
scholar you see I've spent many an hour
scouring the archives for knowledge of
that fateful plot the world has Roger's
Allure guy if you intend to put it to
rights you'd better understand what
happened to make it this way
thing is to blame for the shape I'm in
now it's like he's talking to me utmost
caution don't disturb the corpse more
than necessary
that makes me think if I mess around
with that thing enough I'll I'll get
heated or something
she gave you the clap
kinda
oh man she gives new birth to new death
Aristocrats it's her destiny
he's long from a [ __ ]
I know it's just the way it sounds I
don't have
a thing
like a convo
okay do I talk to him again still need
something
nope
do I go to FIA now
Ryan trouble if I do
it's gonna happen here
apparently you guys know more about this
questline than I do
now you have to rest on a Grace and talk
to you okay
Blue Sky
thanks for the three months man I hope
you have a good year as well thank you
bro
thank you thank you
okay
she was enslaved and forced to bring
back Rick
old dead men instead of those she
thought deserved it
man
I am pleased to see you again would you
like me to hold you once more oh God the
blessing
you guys are being weird you guys are
being weird man
have a freak out
now I go rest
hi Stephen
you can hold me anytime
I help anytime
I miss the simple lore of the Giant on
the tower in Dark Souls 3. would you
like me to hold you once more
yes Mommy
come closer
hi mug
I'm dude I'm telling you guys sometimes
I listen to what you're saying and I
read the comments on my videos you are
so
I read them very warm and I go
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
okay in secret I was no
where I come from after I received the
warmth and Lively Vigor from a number of
Champions I lay
I'm good dark how about you
to Grant him
I was awakened
by the guidance of Grace
and chaste from my birthplace okay like
the painting at the beginning right
despite where she's laying with that guy
I still
a Deathbed
Compass so please
let me hold you like this as often as it
takes
no one responds that quickly thanks man
oh I read every message in my chat every
single one sometimes I don't answer
because I don't want to but I read every
message bro thank you for the two
dollars I'm glad I answered you probably
oh man
doo doo good that means you're still
mentally healthy I you know hopefully I
hope so
I hope so she was supposed to reborn
that guy that makes sense yeah I see her
as laying with him laying with him you
know what I mean read this [ __ ] you Nick
okay sorry all right do you know my dear
have you ever heard of black knife
Prince dear Roger likes to talk of them
went a bed and the ancient plot
which the first of the demigods was
slain the black knives wielded by the
Assassins who committed the ACT along
with the Impressions they made
somehow hide the truth of the conspiracy
these Grand Affairs are hardly my forte
but dear Roger began to weep as he spoke
so she watched him sleep
guys
I'm gonna say something right now
700 hours
700 hours
how do some of you have more hours than
me that blows my mind it is my job to
play this game
I guess I took like a three month break
but
guys
I have literally never heard that
I've never heard that before
wow
no clue
tons of playthroughs
I've never heard that
crazy
I got that from that conversation that
she watches Roger's sleep
which I guess that's what she does right
holy [ __ ]
we breathe Grace apparently I need to
get my act together and get on your
level because God damn holy moly
okay
about the black knife
I've heard tell from someone else
about the black knife Prince that
Fascinate dear Rocher so
clue but it wouldn't be right to give
this to him
stuck as he is in the round table hole
perhaps you could make use of it
okay this is making sense to me I'm not
gonna say anything out loud until I
fully understand it but
let's look at that we're doing a lore
playthrough right now like we're not
even being a wizard oh I guess we're a
wizard aren't we okay
that is
a map
knife okay bats
okay
a simple map given by FIA a clue of the
whereabouts of the Black Knight
fingerprint
I'm just gonna look at it
and I'm gonna think of where this is
it's near a minor archery one
and it's near one of the like places you
get a memory Stone
it's our
I have somewhere around a thousand hours
and honestly I get more motivated to
play and discover more because of your
videos well that's good apparently I
have no idea what I'm doing but I'm glad
you like the videos
I mean it's got to be in larinia
what what does that text say can I zoom
I cannot
okay
you are becoming Odin yeah you guys
remember the ending of Odin how that
ended for him
Black Knight friend from the black knife
catacombs
I mean that makes sense
lorenia
it's right here right yep it's right
here
you see this little dick formation it's
right in there chat
we're gonna have to go on a long ride
actually I can get up there from here
where can I get the meteorite staff it's
in caled
we went there immediately and grabbed it
you don't need to know what you're doing
to be successful
I'm out here doing my best
that's pretty much all I can do
did you guys like my deductive reasoning
my detective skills right there it
looked like a dick so
that narrowed it down for me huh
I'm a genius
definitely on the level of batsy video
in Smoketown wouldn't you say
just as smart smart as it gets
God
maybe I'll stick to really dumb theories
that make people angry
yeah I'm gonna say it I firmly believe
that Nicola is not in the Cocoon
you can take it or leave it
get mad I'm just kidding I think it's
him
I don't know where I'm going
can I get up there from here
I actually can't
is there Laura behind why it looks like
a dick I hope not
watch that be like Godwin's dick growing
out of the ground
it's huge
I thought there was a place I could like
jump up
over here
okay I won't talk about Ragnarok sorry
you're not gonna get a PC port for Years
bro
how long did it take for God of War One
like three years
look at this guy [ __ ] you
I can say I very rarely ever come over
this direction
okay I was just wrong
I was just incorrect on where I thought
I was
be right here isn't there a way to get
up right here
let me try that sorry
um
hi RJ
I just don't want to go all the way back
to the lake facing Cliff brace and then
run all the way but I could
it's over
I died
Serpentine
didn't shoot at me
how evil do you think mikola is
are you kidding me I looked at chat and
now I'm down mother
it's not that big of a deal
not that big of a deal
right back on track baby
nope that was my fault I'm the streamer
I'm the one reading chat you guys are
supposed to talk
foreign
I have to go around
hey it's up here that there's a lift
top
right
thank you
sometimes I think I am going insane
[Music]
now we go this way
I'm just beelining right there
or should I beat this tibia let's beat
this tibia
let's beat her up
the hill
too far
is this just going to be ridiculously
easy
does she have ranged attacks
he's trying to take cover behind the
tree
foreign
would it matter if he was mug
foreign
being a Wizard's really hard work
I had to dodge a lot of stuff there
I'm sure it'll get harder later
hi bloodborne
I wanna kiss you
press one and chat if you want to kiss
me
you do PVP not a lot
I tried
all right good to know
good to know chat good to know all right
you need much more in blue than red I
mean that's the goal my friend
that's the goal
big two Stephen doesn't want me to do
any cosplays chat and he doesn't want to
kiss me
what what kind of viewer
notice your 100
000 subscriber
nah
I don't know who they are
any of any one of you could just say I'm
the one
I'm the one
I found that people either really enjoy
PVP or
or really enjoy PVP PVE
I really enjoy PVE
I find the PVP to just be annoyingly
laggy
you know
you know what I'm saying
nothing against you I'm just that guy
I'm just that guy
you know
oh God thanks man you're welcome Stephen
I love you
thanks for the two bucks
I appreciate it
okay there's our tower now we go we
gotta go down the dick path
a long ride over here
foreign look at the stars
[Music]
wow hey what's up there I don't know if
I've ever been up here before
I have
but probably like one time
look at all the jellyfish
this is interesting
oh yeah I remember this guy
you guys think I can even get through
the catacombs
foreign
from Castle soul out here
do I have to face him yeah
I have so many questions chat
foreign
there it is
farmed him this morning for his armor
it's weird he doesn't go away
you can get help from D since you can't
summon the black knife
gotcha I find PVP specifically invasions
to be fun mix up during a run where my
friend and I can get destroyed or
completely annihilate someone for the
sin of the invasion
that's one thing I've never tried is
invasions
the coliseums are a great idea that they
they need to
give reason for people to to play it
like you got to give them a reward for
doing it you know what I mean
foreign
oh yeah [ __ ]
because I liked it for a couple days and
then I was like why am I doing this
there's like no reason
it's just kind of like
all right
dude the carrion slicer
is Bonkers bro
why are you growing back
oh there's a dude isn't there there's a
dude
all right we're gonna live chat we're
gonna be fine
there you are
yeah I'm saying just like if if you win
a PVP fight in the Coliseum you should
get a rune Arc or something which is
like that would be fine I don't even
think you get that many runarchs in the
game
I stopped playing Elder ring after I 100
it and I want to ask you if you can kill
roderica at stormhill cat Shack of
course you can
you insane person
I think I just got bigger checked really
hard
like really really hard
we'll live though
because I technically can't die
imagine killing roderica
I'm scared
foreign
where am I going
hopefully this is the right way
ah
somewhere a heavy door is open well
thank you
[Music]
open open the thing come on open the
thing
I couldn't move dude
he literally swung as soon as I came out
of the animation and I I couldn't move
all right well I guess I opened the door
where's the door though
it was right here
okay who's in here though
oh
[Music]
um
foreign
shade
all right
Well Chad I gotta Beat the Boss
to get the runes
to uh
level vigor
and also last time I leveled Vigor y'all
yelled at me
also I have the bulldogan's blessing on
which I'm sure can't help our situation
right
thank you
I feel like I should just do distance
nice
all right what'd that give me
is that what we wanted
we got death root I mean that's that's
good
I bet I have to go somewhere else for
the print don't I
rip 8 000 runes dog 8 000 runes is like
dropping a penny out of my pocket dog
I don't give a [ __ ]
you can kill any NPC in the game
secret boss huh
foreign
crab
crab
run
for a double crab
you're killing your own babies
[ __ ] you
ah
this skeleton is doing everything in his
power to kill me
stop running
stop it
ride one of what ride one of the knife
things
ride one of the night things
why am I aiming at something past him
weird
oh the knife things
I I get what you mean now
didn't I I already did that I literally
already did that
I did
now I gotta go back
I have to go up another one
where I was killed
bruh
so there's just another path inside the
already hidden path
[Music]
the life of a wizard
oh there's an invisible wall gotcha
I'm definitely getting Vigor checked
right now I feel like I should not be
here but here we are being
going big dick you know
I can't upgrade shut up chat
level vigor
okay
okie dokie
almost got knifed up there
foreign
wall you speak of
it's right here
right here oh
[Music]
I'm the best player in the game
no one's better than me
okay
sorry I'll put my ego in check
Real and True
It's gotta be that wall right there yeah
here okay
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
should I slice her up
yo yo chill
I had no stamina
[ __ ]
dude this is such a small room for this
[Music]
there's no stagger
do I have to come do I have to run all
the way back there
oh I can use D there you guys said that
earlier
I have to run all the way back
that that little tiny ass Arena
is insane and my carrion slicer is not
very good
not the best
yeah I know you guys told me
and do you remember that I have ADHD I'm
dyslexic and I don't remember everything
you told me
because you say a lot
all right I'm dead
please don't kill me
after I kill her I'm just gonna die to
the skeletons
I got this
something to stagger her
that's what you get for backing up a lot
foreign
what
[Music]
okay Stephen I'm obviously talking about
everyone
[Music]
look at look at my Mom finally becoming
a great room
that's my real mom by the way Chad AGT
mom
everyone say w mom
thanks Mom
appreciate it
carrion slicer I was using carrion
slicer it was not that good against her
[Music]
thank you thank you
it's my real mom
okay
let's go
um that grab is Bonkers sorry
foreign
[Music]
that was a good time to do that
yep
what in tarnation
they're right there
foreign
not hard
easy
first try
all right is that all I need to do I got
the print what does it say is it a key
item
yeah it is why can I print Mark of the
Knight of black knives ritual
on the night of the black knives someone
stole a fragment of Death From malachyth
the Black Blade and imbued its power
into the Assassin's daggers this Mark is
evidence of the ritual
and rides the truth of conspiracy
sounds very political
L politics
and guess what else chat I didn't level
vigor
I probably should though
D level Vigor says drips okay got it
I have way too much bigger going on
so I give that to rajier
alright guys
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna pop all these
boys
AGT mom gives me strength every day
he's a great mom
every day
you have an extra step with Ronnie but
just fast traveling that's fine that's
fine
we're already there
Roger didn't level Vigor and look what
happened to him
he's fine he just gets to hang out with
a blanket in the round table forever
that was the most unsatisfying one level
I've ever had okay so I go to Roger
right
so you said
or are you gonna be like no you have to
go here first and then someone else can
go no you go to Roger first
I got a text
you
uh
okay
hand him that okay okay cabbage okay
let's type it all out always good to see
you safe so
what do you need
Roger then Ronnie got it this is a black
knife print
I could scarcely believe you managed to
get your hands on this you recall our
conversation about the night of the
black knives yes they say the Assassins
who carried out the deed were signs of
the Eternal City the Newman group
entirely of women in armor of silver
under cloaks which fooled the eye the
knives they wielded though were imparted
with the power of the Rune of death
through Sinister right please I beg of
you lend me the knife print for a time
I'd love nothing more than to tease out
its Secrets though only a fragment a
very specific ritual had to be performed
to impart the power of the Rune of death
traces of the one who performed the
right are sure to remain in the imprint
half my body has been suffused with
death
I'm certain it will help me see
thank you
okay
so do I rest and talk to him or do I go
to Ronnie because I feel like
I gotta get his take right
first
ah hello yeah I was hoping to see you my
examination is complete
here's the knife print back with my
thanks
okay now I have a fairly good idea who
performed the ride upon the blade the
person who orchestrated the night it's
Ronnie's Luna princess Ronnie one of the
children born to King consort Radigan
and his first wife ranala okay demigod
and sister to General radon and pray to
Reichard we knew all this was the name I
discovered in the imprint truly you have
my thanks but if I might be so bold I
would like to ask something more of you
if Rani truly is the one who plotted
that fateful night then she should bear
the curse mark of destined to death
somewhere upon her flesh I would like
you to procure it for me and then all
will be laid bare I will have the
answers I've sought for so long
is he talking about
um her body on top of the carrion Tower
Divine Tower
because there is a fat mark on her back
and it has that
yeah
you guys know what I'm talking about
yeah
he will deny you now but after another
visit to Roger you're good
Ronnie's whereabouts I have some idea of
Ronnie's potential whereabouts got it
got it there's a manner to the north of
the Academy of Raya lucarion it is the
familial home of the car I will say the
Knight of black knives has been very
confusing for me
there in recent years Ronnie's
whereabouts since the shattering are a
well-kept secret she hasn't been seen
even once but I suspect she might have
returned to the Manor in which she was
born
okay so now we go to Ronnie
the evil [ __ ] stamp yourself right the
curse mark
the death Rune is not on the body I mean
no the mark on it is on her body
do not visit celibus got it
dude I want to know what Ronnie really
looked like before she was a doll
I mean her body is literally burnt to a
crisp so we have like somewhat of an
idea but man
I want to see like her hair and all that
stuff
I really hope they do time travel for
DLC just so we can see everyone before
all this stuff happen
okay I I'm talking to her oh
again we cross paths yeah there's
definitely not a good or bad side in
this game
well last we met
pleased with me to see torrent Hale and
heart
and heart tarnished
business has thou here
I have no memory of inconvenient
invitation
you must be Ronnie the witch behind the
Knight of black knives this is a no
we've done two things today that I've
literally never done that's crazy thank
you chat this this helps me a lot in in
understanding what's going on
okay I see
quite the sleuth aren't we
indeed I am the witch Ronnie I stole a
fragment of the Rune of death
and used it to forge the god slaying
black knives through fearsome right I
did it all but sadly for thee
the curse mark though that she did not
deny [ __ ] found here I have slain the
body I was born into and casted away and
it is upon that flesh the curse mark is
carved yep
oh
where did the body go dude this is crazy
I've never seen this before
and why should I reveal that to thee I
love her perform the ACT not to bury the
past she's so sassy Shame of the Deeds
all the same
[Music]
I didn't think so yes Mark those Secret
s not here
that's all I will say it's not here
be gone it's not here guys
God damn that's crazy
wow okay well is she just like she don't
want anything to do with me
now
the curse mark though sickest is not
here
that's all I will say
be gone
[Music]
so how do we get to the tower now
considering you don't look into this
stuff from other creators and don't
normally go down these kinds of paths
it's cool see you finding stuff new to
you yeah I I don't watch other creators
that's for my mental health
um I wish I didn't have to do that but I
do because you know like one Creator
will say something another Creator will
say something else I just go down these
rabbit holes and I'm just I just get
ultimately more confused
just way more confused so I've stopped
doing that and my understanding has
gotten better and better since I've done
that
you need to go back to Roger
I don't I don't know why I don't just
say Roger but it you know it's
rajin
comparison is the theme of Joy I agree
son
what do you need I wish I didn't have to
do that though Ronnie cast off her curse
mark I see
when Ronnie shed her flesh she shed the
curse mop too you know not everyone
would trust such a Tale But if she in
her current form is nothing more than
the living doll you profess then perhaps
it's true after all
forgive the bluntness of the notion but
how would you like to become one of
rani's vassals ah only in order to get
what we want of course the location of
the body which for the curse mark which
right now I haven't the faintest I know
where it is to find out
poke around
people want to trust you
I've seen it
proposition can you become Ronnie's
vassal to advance our agenda while in
her service you'll be able to take a
poke around on the slide okay and if I
realize that I'm asking you to put
yourself in grave danger oh sorry but I
know you've got what it takes
quite possibly the only one in fact
I mean okay so clearly she did not want
to be known for doing that
obviously
why would she need to hide though like
why would she even give a [ __ ]
you know
I want I want all the help I played the
game enough you guys you guys can help
me out if you want
well okay I just offered a serve now
like did my character just not think of
that before
interesting
it seems like she does not like me
you know
whoops
where the [ __ ] am I okay oh I just got
so confused
what would you like with elder ring DLC
time travel
take me to the Knight of black knives
and the shattering as it's happening
she didn't expect the
Knight of black knives had such a
terrible influence since she's ashamed
of it
are you like are we taking is that she's
ashamed of it I I don't see it that way
at all Miro even after this
she's not ashamed of it she just doesn't
want people to know her full plan she
doesn't want people investigating what
she's doing
which we are which is like that's why
she's like piss off
don't go any deeper you know what I mean
but if we say it well I want to help you
do
smoggy kissed is not here I mean that's
how I see it
no
I wish to serve you oh is that so that
will Trend me Aid
I propose
Lord in thyself
curse marks location no doubt see look
she's so smart she already knows what
we're trying to do there's nothing wrong
with a well-laid scheme even again
if my past and past wounds back into
thee I am curious enough to see what thy
Destiny portends she doesn't even care
she's like all right let's go I know
what you're doing let's see what happens
good hunting today
that's that's really cool holy [ __ ] good
wow proceed with haste there is in my
service he's that smart she knew exactly
what we were doing
by the name of Blythe I would have they
join him in searching for the hidden
treasure it is obvious the Eternal City
well Roger was like you know we'll be on
the sly and Ronnie was like I know what
you're doing take from him the
particulars that's awesome
and there will thou find I've heard all
this before my War counselor
kind of like Fallout where you have
Charisma doing just the same
that'd be cool okay let's go talk to
them
yeah you are blowing my mind right now
with this
it's like I knew I knew of all this but
I didn't know the particulars
yeah I like it
yeah Roger's clearly playing
Checkers and Ronnie's playing 3D chess
that's a great way to put it so you were
the one he knows what's going on she's
been around a long time
again I am Egypt
Ariana
and Lady Iran
anyone tell me
are we the hero of the story
Elden ring does not have a hero
there is no good or bad in Eldon rings
it is simply what everyone wants my
apologies does that make sense for the
misleading words of warning I never
imagined that an audience let alone
service to Lady Rami was in your fate
I for one should have seen it no
but I did not excellent do forgive me
my fellow it does depend on your
perspective and your playthroughs but in
general there is no hero oh lady Ronnie
besides torrent
horns the hero
okay I think we have to talk to all of
them right
long time friend life
have you forgotten glad to have you in
the service of mistress Rani well
someone can't remember and it didn't pop
up I'm still in Lim grave the Eternal
City wait you told me how to pronounce
your name yesterday
I'm planning to go below through the
well in the Mist wood your name hits my
dyslexia so hard it's insane bro
or
urticated
I took iterate a dude you have fours in
your name and it's [ __ ] me I'm sorry
thank you for becoming a great Rune I
appreciate it I don't know why my alerts
aren't working
but thank you
I appreciate it
I think it worked on here but not unlike
this
hopefully it'll pop up but thank you
thank you altercated I can't the four in
there just makes my brain just not work
okay
altercated thank you
I see
I'm skipping his dialogue I'm sorry but
since I I can't even listen to this guy
talk
but who
can't do it
I'm gone
he's he's probably my least favorite in
the game to be honest
he's the evil villain I'll say that
see that works
oh I might know why
stop
what you got imagine how powerful
reichardt would have been if he
canonically killed us like at that point
you usually have around two to three
great rooms it would have been
terrifying to see his power wait why
doesn't Reichard eat us
is it because he can't like do do we
fade away and go back to grace before he
can eat us and take our power
that's a good quote that's a good I man
yeah no kidding
Peru
and thank you for the um 6.75 Super Chat
that's big thank you Gustav I appreciate
it
he does eat you in his grab kill yeah he
does but he doesn't get the power I
wonder that's because we fade away you
know what I mean
so he doesn't digest us
that's a theory that's a video right
there
that's a video that'll make people go
wait wait wait wait because you guys
know the only Reichard video I've made
was called what if Reichard ate Godwin
and I had a theory that Reichard ate
Godwin
and everyone was like dog shut up it was
everyone was so mad about that one dude
I don't think I was right in any way but
man people were mad
they were so mad
that was months and months and months
ago
ain't see anybody talk about it I've
only made one Reichard video because I
hate snakes
I'm I'm real weird
I'm I'm such a weird person
allow me to forewarn you like I gotta be
in the mood to make videos you know what
I mean like I gotta be in it and
reichardt scares me to a point where I
don't even want to do it this body is
not without it since
still
I have
I look forward to the good news when I
arise
yeah I like reichard's legs they're uh
they're cute
I soon enter my slumber
it's like
I have her dialogue to the good news
because rice because there's like we
just walk up here and say I'm not really
here for any reason and she talks to us
like oh you should join me her her tone
of voice
is so different because I've done the
the other side of this so many times I'm
I'm noticing the tone difference in the
dialogue where with the other dialogue
she talks to us like with this dialogue
the the way we're doing it with her now
where it's like hey you did the Knight
of black knives
he talks to us like she's pissed like
I don't I don't I can't do it myself but
there's a tone difference
he's talking to us literally different
I think it's cool
I thought the double back from Roger was
just messed up and so weird
why
yeah I know it's the reason she gives us
the Statue
with the black knife be able to actually
kill Reichard
is it possible to kill gods
then would it be able to kill the
immortal serpent
I mean he literally says like you can't
kill me like reichardt is not dead
when we kill him so
that I don't know
cabbage is a spammer
type it all type out type it all out
instead of spamming
get it get a coherent thought out
if an empirion stage it no problem okay
so am I just doing the normal questline
now
by the way
he also explains why she she is
surprised to see you later she thinks
you're done
where's he surprised
okay so we want to go
Down Under
right
way the heck over here
yeah she's asleep until we get the the
thingy
the Finger Slayer blade that's what she
needs
she doesn't think a tarnish can complete
the task
crew
all right I do have to kill radon
but I have to get the Landell to open a
radon's fight
[Music]
what do you guys think we should do
why did she go to sleep she just says
it's a it's a hindrance of the doll you
know what I mean
that's all we know about why she has to
sleep
I can't imagine we'll fight reichardt
again in DLC possibly a more powerful
and deformed version of him well I I
think it would be
uh
we fight tanith whatever she becomes
after consuming him
we can get the dactus medallions we
could do that
that's the easiest way or we can kill
the magma worm which I don't like the
magma worm way
I really don't
I'm not a fan of that whole area
we should go find Millicent and stuff
and we can get The dactus Medallion over
there when we go that direction
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay I have a plan in my head let's go
get the first medallion
you can kill tanith
yeah you can
I don't know
that's true
why is she consuming him then
doesn't she do it to take his power
oh God
[Music]
hello welcome
a customer goodbye yes what
yeah The Crucible voice shows up and
then you like can't
do we like I don't know if tanith really
dies if you do kill her you know what I
mean
yeah no you can't kill her
oh also can I get rid of this chat can I
use the balticans blessing and not have
low Health now
I am an L customer
oh boy oh God
I had no idea the pumpkin head could do
that
wow
I had no idea that was a thing we're
learning all kinds of stuff today
that was crazy
he has a [ __ ]
whatever
run
foreign
you guys keep telling me not to level my
Vigor and I feel like I should
or is this just the life
of
a
wizard
you die quick that's how it is
foreign
okay
we got one now we go
where
where is this place again
this way
I feel like if I go here I'll be close
you're a wizard Harry
less than average bigger because they
typically go ranged however if you can
add more yeah yeah I got you I got you
thank you
you think torrent is more special than
we think
is he not special
Torrance the best
I love torrent
yeah what's my limit on Vigor chat what
are you gonna let me do
so can we kill this bird tree
you think
what a [ __ ] throw
nope bye bye
that's a big old note for me chief
40.
okay
now we're just spamming again
cabbage I'm gonna tell you never mind
you're fine
not a doubt
you can do no hit runs if you wanted
I mean if I put enough time into it I
bet I could
take a while though I think we can go to
it eventually
all right Rogers
Rapier here is awful by the way
it is not very good
you guys are really saying 30 health max
what am I at
24
could do that
all right
let's go
they all knowing whoa that's a big gifty
boy oh my God
oh
oh I have to skip all these
four four four four four
Mr GB with the 10 great Rune memberships
that is big oh God
well you didn't even show up any nothing
happened
it broke
let's go if you got a gift in membership
for Mr GB make sure to say thank you
that is huge
ten gifted and we're over a hundred boys
103. I think a bunch of uh resubs just
came in by the way
a whole bunch
all right we'll do the run
we'll do the run
of uh the wheel of level or what do you
guys want to call that is Wheel of level
the right name
we will do the run
pull out the spinning now no that's
gotta be its own thing
no cosplay
we that could be another thing
wheel of runes
that doesn't particularly mean the level
though
is it just wheel of levels
the wheel of stat level
is that too many words
you're about to run out of people to
become members
you can gift Oh wait we're at 93.
why did it go down
never mind we need seven more
I was gonna say that wasn't enough Stone
coffins you find drones at what if they
are a punishment it would be very
difficult for the Earth trees roots to
touch you in a stone coffin above ground
and give you a rebirth
Archie's roots
oh that's a good theory too Gustav and
thank you for the another 10 super chat
I appreciate it
thank you so here's what happened chat
we went down and it went up because the
whole thing the thing is broken and then
it fixed itself
so whenever somebody gifts memberships
right now
it will also resub the people
that they gifted the memberships to and
then it realizes oh wait
it's one thing instead of two and then
went back down and fixed itself
YouTube get your [ __ ] together fix all
this stuff
but it does fix itself we're at 93 so we
need seven more and then we'll do it
I like that theory Gustav and GB thank
you very much that's big I really
appreciate it
at least it goes at least it fixes
itself
it shouldn't be able to gift to a member
yeah it shouldn't
and I think I was gonna say it'll gift
to random people as well or I think it
gives to a person who's already a member
and extends their membership or
something
I don't know I have to go in and mess
with it a lot
but now we can go
I have the key
we can just go here
all right let's go
it also explains why you find runes they
couldn't return so they clumped up
he gives to random people only
yeah it's always random I wish you could
pick somebody too because you can do
that on Twitch
where you just like want to gift a
specific person a sub or remember
wow
thanks chibi
I'm glad you think I'm a good streamer I
would say I enjoy streaming more than
making videos
um
but I love making videos too
memberships are tied to people watching
The Stream So after a while some streams
Plateau like one streamer plateaued for
months and use Bots to get new members
plateaus
wouldn't it just give to like random
people
they like don't even have to be in your
stream that's what twitch does
foreign
how to play chess
not a clue
it doesn't do random
so you can only gift members to the
people who are in your stream
huh
so what if you had like one viewer
and they were already a member could you
just not get any memberships
it's dependent on viewers on streams I
got a membership for a stream I watched
but wasn't a sub
so you just have to be in the Stream at
some point
oh
I need to look at the rules for
memberships and stuff
and goes by chat while you're streaming
the rules do
you have to chat chat and type but
before you get one
huh
I wonder why they do that
Logan
to the tarnish
good to have you Logan
thank you thank you
I appreciate it
welcome we're at 94 out of 100. we've
gotten 33 members today let's go baby
also this number right here chat it can
go down when people cancel their resub
or their re-membership I always say sub
because I streamed on Twitch for years
Um this can always go down depending on
the day this is the overall total number
of members we have this is how many
we've gotten today this can always go
down if people like cancel their re
membership
or let's say I don't stream for forever
that too
I like listening to Melina
those of Queen America
here no I promised a Ronnie cosplay at
500 members
but that's a long time from now I would
assume
we don't even have 500 viewers so you're
saying I literally can't do it
in America's own words
thrown in the sewers
the choice is dying I don't know become
one with the order
or divest thyself of it to wallow at the
fringes I'm displaying the game Peter
powerless up
even said Stephen no cosplay no I didn't
I said that for a hundred I don't know
why you don't want a cosplay I think
that'd be hilarious
you're very adamant about this
but I was gonna do it at 100. and you
were like no
so we changed it
but I did say for 500 that we do Ronnie
cosplay
or it was a thousand
I don't know
[Music]
you don't want to see me all blue and
[ __ ] that'd be cool
[Music]
I think you're right Taryn
foreign
if each demigod won and achieved their
goals would be fun
I kind of already no I did I didn't
already do that
I made a demigod video a few months ago
yeah it's called the true power
the demigod's true power I think is what
it's called
a blide cosplay guys we can think of
other things besides cosplays as well
like maybe if I was a cute girl cosplays
would be really fun
so yeah
please do a cosplay I literally Super
Chat 50 to see you cross dress I'll do
it I've done it before I did it on
Twitch for a long time
I dressed up as uh
who is it
they all [ __ ] uh
Princess Peach from Mario
GB again
oh holy moly
dude you actually lag out my everything
wow
[Music]
GB
[Music]
W's in the chat for GB
God damn
all right we're now we're doing it
we're definitely doing it now there's no
way it goes below
we hit it I'll do it is one I know
okay I'm gonna skip this
I didn't do that I gotta fix this [ __ ]
man
W's in the chat GB
I I don't know what you're doing but I
appreciate it man thank you very much
these are all great Rune memberships
which isn't even the cheapest membership
just so you guys know or unless you
can't not do that for gifted I don't
know
thank you GB No Escape now I'm not
trying to escape I want to do all this
[ __ ]
now here's the here's the question chat
so we're gonna do the wheel of level run
sometime soon probably this week
but what do you wanna what's the next
goal
200
I think it should be 250.
now twist it's going crazy
they all know it dude I gotta change the
goal
Twisted with the five gifted members
man
Ronnie cosplay 250.
I dude
[Music]
we have to work on the next goal
I don't know if Ronnie cosplay is at
250.
why am I suddenly a member
holy Twisted thank you very much I'm
gonna skip these okay perfect
see now we're at 109 I don't get it that
thing like Auto adjusts in the weirdest
way let me reload or something maybe
yeah 109.
I'm confused
Melania 250 Ronnie is fine I think
Ronnie should be 500 because that one is
crazy
like I'll have to go get a witch hat and
like decorate it to look like hers and
then get blue paint all over my face
Esther thank you for the resub too are
you planning to play other games after
this not right now no
Elden ring seems to be
the one and only
get an Elden ring tattoo at 250 dog
that's like a thousand
for me to get a permanent mark on my
body
that would be like a thousand members
that would be crazy
you have to go all out cosplay for 500.
I would try my best
bathe your head dude no look look at my
hair I have a ponytail right now
I am not shaving my head this is all a
bunch of work
it's a bunch of work to grow your hair
get reichard's face on your own
oh
my
God
bruh
no you can't Trey it's really dumb
Christian
welcome baby
good to have you here thanks for
becoming a great room
welcome welcome welcome
hmm I'm trying to think of something I
think the next goal should be 250 and
then the one after that is 500.
but what are we gonna do for 250
let me change the goal
because you guys are crazy
there we go now it's too fitty
dye your hair at 250. no dude
no
I don't want to dye my hair
Elden ring IRL
why can't YouTube let people give
memberships on mobile I don't know
donate 250 members at 200. haha
well you guys think I'm rich no that's
like a thousand dollars or something
dye your beard
I don't even have a beer dude I have
five o'clock shadow beard that's all I
can do unfortunately
become the Elden Lord bring a friend in
and do a speed run
e level one run
yeah we couldn't think of more challenge
runs to do
no hit run
we'd be here for weeks months
Cowboy Bebop Harry run
you look like a man-child
a lot of guys have five o'clock Shadows
double boss spawn run
I think we should do that
because there is a mod where I can make
two of every enemy in the game
and every boss so there'd be two radons
two millennias and we try and beat the
game like that someone did it with like
four
I think I would go for two
because I'm not a God okay like some
people are
double boss no HUD I feel like double
boss is already enough
we got to figure this out
do a randomizer
we already did a randomizer
shave your eyebrows do why do you guys
want me to be ugly
you think Godwin was a mage
I think he used fundamental
incantations
I don't know if that makes him a mage
do a nipple review a reveal wow
okay let's not get banned
don't do RL stuff
oh real life I thought you meant rocket
League
I think that's what we have to do
Twisted we're super far off 250 so we
don't have to figure it out
keep coming up with ideas I really like
the double boss
definitely not doing uh that
the nipple reveal
all right maybe we gotta figure it out
because
that's 20 gifted
from Logan holy moly Logan
um
dude
gotta fix my alerts cause they're broken
I mean here doing nothing you guys are
going crazy
there we go
[Music]
okay
Logan
what the heck man thank you very much
W's in the chat for Logan I really
appreciate all the support that I chat
this is insane
you know before yesterday we've gotten a
total of like 20 members total
what the [ __ ] Logan
Jesus
it broke it just doesn't say anything
I'm invested now
with the 50 Super Chat apparently you're
invested
that's an investment that's invested
holy crap
all right I mean [ __ ] dude you guys
really like incentives don't you
man we're at 150 oh my God all right
how about this
we're gonna so make sure everyone here
join the Discord especially if you're a
new member join the members only Discord
okay
we have two discords one that's normal
that has a lot more people and then the
new member Discord go to the community
tab make sure you join that all that
stuff okay
I have two ideas for the 250.
let me know if this is against TOs
for this idea
every death
I take a shot
of like vodka I don't know a shot of
something
and do a drunk play through
every death I take a shot
god dude I'm gonna die I'm never gonna
win because Melania is gonna kill me
so
I'll have to like make a super build
is that okay though
what is happening
sure
has remedy
yeah well I'm double invested
it's a hundred dollar Super Chat from
Gustav
in your Australian currency
I think that's Australian with this
67-53 Super Chat holy crap thank you
very very much
what is happening I'm standing here it's
kinda funny Jake just increased
subscribers and members over a week
without Bots or anything Jake will end
in alcoholic Como after millennia
as long as it's not the complete focus
of the stream angel thank you Gustav
thank you Logan thank you GB thank you
everybody thank you
Logan
thank you everybody thank you I really
appreciate it I'm like not even moving
not doing anything
this is nuts I I really appreciate it
alcohol is just bad do something better
I think that would be fun though
maybe not every death
Maybe
I don't know I think that's a good idea
though I'll have uh we'll do the
um
they all knowing
what's happening
[Music]
that was 50
gifted members from Logan
yes
and five gifted from Brian
oh Father
is this gonna play 50 times
what you guys are doing
[Music]
what's going on
all
well Witness
I concede to Logan
it's not a competition
[Music]
wow
I don't know what to say
witness is this all I had to do
was mentioned that memberships exist
[Music]
he said that was the last one for me
love your stuff I love you Logan
I'm glad you like it man and I really
appreciate all the support Brian thank
you for the five as well everyone for
the support you're crazy man
never seen this on you on YouTube ever
I've never seen this happen
I gotta start skipping these
I need to set a reminder to fix the
alerts
fourth
half half half
forefathers
oh
[Music]
fourth
fourth
wow we did it
okay this should be that was the last
one I love your stuff that was the last
okay for me love your stuff Logan you
are officially a legend in the channel
along with
Brian
Gustav
[ __ ]
fgb every everyone's here everyone here
is a legend I appreciate it man
thank you all very much
I don't know I don't even know what to
say I I'm literally been standing here
20 minutes just in awe
[Music]
what was that
oh Brian gifted two more thank you Brian
holy [ __ ]
well Witness
and then you became an Elden Lord
up just upgraded the membership didn't
even know you could do that
thank you Logan
for upgrading your membership to like
the highest one it was like a lot of
money still
a head tattoo how many are we at 175
I feel like we have to figure this out
now because we're we're way closer
got over 100 today
I feel like I should just go like full
screen and just stand around and talk I
I don't know all right
look I moved a little bit okay here we
go
all right okay I'm gonna start moving
now because I'm gonna lose my mind
uh pick a good one you'll be there for
the weekend
I say double Boss run
press one in chat if you want that
not double boss double of every enemy in
the game
there'd just be two of everything
ooh drips
play a Fight Club winner gets a reward
that's an idea drips and thank you for
the 10 super chat thank you very much he
said 250 player Fight Club winner gets a
reward
of an entire Fight Club
yes angel
will do every every incentive we will do
at some point
you're a rare valuable Underdog YouTuber
and everyone knows it
oh that's really nice I appreciate that
yeah some players don't play on the same
console or uh yeah platform so that'd be
really hard to put together I love that
idea though drips
and I would like to do a PVP tournament
at some point
I think we said this when we did that
stream
The Fight Club stream that they need to
make some updates kind of like they did
in Dark Souls 3. where we could do
something like that hopefully they do I
love that idea though but the way the
coliseums are set up right now
it just wouldn't work
it'd just be way too hard to keep track
of
I love that idea though
I so everyone make sure to join the
Discord
and I will
I will have people vote over there how
about that
we'll do a vote in the Discord and you
get you guys can pick okay
so make sure you join the members only
Discord because that's where I'm gonna
do it go to the community Tab and then
you'll see a link to the members only
this is getting old stop spending money
as Twisted upgrades to an Elden Lord as
well
thank you twisted you're you're a legend
as well I I really you're an Elden Lord
I really appreciate all the support guys
thank you very much
I'm like kind of in shock right now I
don't know what to do
I can't find it in the join Discord
how you just go to the community tab
and then you go to the member Discord
the Normie Discord is in the description
like right below the Stream
play on PC only I mean I do
I do yeah
what were we doing
oh we wanted to activate we're done now
let's go fight radon close I don't think
we can beat further till the foot of the
earth tree
neighborhood is fulfilled it takes me
back I'm trying to stop at the foot of
the air tree I have to thank everybody
that gave me my purpose all right or
would you guys rather me do this
everything is lost to me all right
thanks for the 50 gifted have to
ascertain for myself the reason for
which I uh thanks for 100 Super Chat and
appreciate and bodyless yep
like all those big streamers bro I don't
know how they do that 100 bucks yeah
thanks man
that bro freaks me out like dude that
guy just gave you a hundred dollars
foreign
we're just gonna brush that off
I'm gonna go get all these golden seeds
as well
it's out a lot
um I'm also going to use this blessing
we'll get the golden seeds we'll we'll
go try radon I don't think it's gonna
happen though
I don't think we can beat Redan
be like doctor disrespect and just
ignore them yeah
Zeta
thank you for the 20.
it's a super sticker and it says thanks
for being you
oh that's sweet thank you
thank you very much
that's sweet
equals why the tree burns
thoughts February equals Melania that's
why the tree burns
thoughts
you're you're suggesting that shabiri is
Melania
Melina
Russia thank you for the two
appreciate it
I am ignoring this boss
for now
I think that's the total opposite
cabreri literally tells you not to kill
Melania
so that you can become the Lord of chaos
instead
and then cries to kill you if you do so
I don't think so
I think that'd be a little cray
[Music]
I'm gonna go ahead and say no to that
one
but you never know man
what the [ __ ] are you guys doing I'm
gonna start cussing
bruh
Christian Wild
oh we got a body this guy right here
just wanted to say thank you for the
awesome content stay wholesome smiley
face
with a 50 Super Chat attached to that
Christian thank you very much
that's very kind I'm glad you like the
content thank you for watching it
Zeta thank you as well I will keep being
myself
I will
thank you guys
Jake's getting rich I
I mean [ __ ] man
oh did I did I tell you guys that um I
got an apartment
and I'm moving in on January 13th
so this this is very helpful toward that
so thank you guys I can I can pay my
rent
thank you I think I can pay my rent
I appreciate that
all right Market time
all right yep it's just gonna be me and
joy in the new apartment
okay that hurt
oh boy oh God
carrying slicer baby
slice it up [ __ ]
I think I'm a little under leveled for
this area what do you think
foreign
I'm scared
I'm doing my best
is he stuck in the hole
that was my fault that was my fault
how's the bow that's not the bow
I just jumped that
Bose bake
Market Palm yourself
he's he's going crazy
come on
he hasn't staggered to the Rock sling a
single time
dude he is like actually
pretty good against him
I think I gotta slice him
almost died
foreign
there guys
holy [ __ ] that was so close
do I need this still
yes
I don't really even eat I well that just
save me so we're good we're fine
why does it transform into morgot it's a
trap
he's trying to he he's trying to stop
you any way he can from getting into the
city
I don't think you can stagger him
morgot's definitely staggerable
but I don't think I'm strong enough to
do so yet
allocate Flash
five
let's listen to
sweet sweet Melina
here as well
shall I share them with you
if you want
in America's own work ouch hear me
demigods
my children beloved why is he speak of
thy selves that which he desire yeah be
it a lord
be it a God but should he fail to become
old at all
you will be forsaken a mounting only to
sacrifices
all right
okay
I love the dialogue in this game so much
cuteness or sex appeal
I think you gotta have a little bit of
both
don't you think
[ __ ] it
seven three or eight two yeah you're
kind of right because
it the blue increases it all the way
every time
I'm gonna do a
I'm gonna do us
a six four for now
hi metal I prefer game sense the sex
appeal
yeah Peru
all right
um let's go to radon let's give it a try
I don't think we can beat redon because
our best thing is Rock sling and I'm
pretty sure he's resistant to rock sling
right
I do not think we can beat redone
still below 100 likes bet
like the Stream
if you want
I can't control you
okay
read the
you killed him with rock sling oh he
isn't
you know what that's actually true that
the things that characters use they're
actually
decently weak to it most of the time
I've been challenged here so I gotta do
it
that was a mistake that was a mistake
I don't think I'm gonna hit him on the
horse
you're a wizard Perry hotter
come on
excellent
cat this is not a winnable fight
yes it is
yes it is
get your head out of the gutter Jake
okay it might not be
I am [ __ ] I [ __ ] the bed
that's all I can say I [ __ ] the bed
right there
bro just want to say your videos help me
get through this game it's honestly been
epic thank you for all the hard work you
put in I'm I'm glad you think so zg
thanks for watching
so anyway you better change the title of
the stream we are way past 100 members
oh yeah should I do that
hmm
no people come in
we'll do that for next stream I'll
change it next stream
asked when he's only facing you directly
yeah
yeah
I think you called Chat Cat instead
you might be
you might be
yo what up Mikey
I might have called you a cat what are
you gonna do about it
cats are cute
cats are cute man
oh he's not gonna be here
that's fine I like the Skybox
we're gonna keep it here
go fight the rot dragon
I think I'd rather poop my pants and
stream for another 24 hours
it's probably a lot easier with as a
wizard
we are kind of cute you are
who thought of the yeah you know whoever
thought of that idea red potato is is a
very handsome person very handsome
the great idea and we hit it by the way
so we're gonna do it at some point
very soon
have you been updating the spreadsheet
not at all
this definitely turned from 100 run into
just kind of like we're playing as a
wizard
but we'll call it that we'll try and do
as much as we can
that was me homie g
I told you about it yesterday
Steven
you're a cat all right
hello
you're a wizard Perry Harry hotter
can I also be a handsome person
I think you're all handsome chat
you're all handsome you're all beautiful
and you is important
you'll hit out 250 before you complete
100 run
maybe what are we at 173 that's still a
lot more man
that's like yeah
that's 75 more 77.
hmm
thought it might find you here Jacob has
the memory of a goldfish
I was a little worried
you're not wrong
it looks like you're still in one piece
right now right good stuff hold Ronnie's
fate in stasis but once he's out of the
way
it'll spring back into motion so now
we stand against the demigod once known
as the strongest of them all the way
ahead is pleasingly simple this was like
the most hyped sword and fine ever
this year when I when I first walked in
here earlier this year when I first
played the game
I've never been more hyped than this
this was so lit still is
[Music]
god of the shattering awaits you you're
never wrong medals
[Music]
[Applause]
defeat the general claim glory and grab
that great Rune we are super dead right
Festival
[Music]
hype ah you came how delightful
indeed I thought I might find you here
welcome Alex do you know for whom this
Festival is being held well
it is none other who would you guys
rather talk to himself mikola or radon
before he went crazy
[Music]
although we get a lot more lore from
Nicola I think but
the fear simply assures me the ordeal is
worth undertaking
be sure to get a good Vantage my friend
I Iron Fist am I allowed to use the
summonsingly brave this audience I think
radon would be so [ __ ] cool
before he went crazy
let's get even more hyped up
good and prepared young Chum with a the
Festival begin scene for the man
like a generated cutscene not in game
all right I'll use the summons allow me
to paint you the full picture
[Music]
General radon is cursed ever to one
[ __ ] mobile
Stephen thank you man have a great rest
of your day thank you for being here
appreciate you
now he gathers the corpses I love
Alexander DD
like a dog
[Music]
howling at the sky
but now
but now we must make Merry oh Gathering
of Champions the rebels begin
the celebration of War
the redone Festival
[Music]
let's do it let's give it a shot
I'm ready willing and able
but now
we must make
I think this this is a smithing Stone
right yeah
a celebration of whoa
I guess so potato
I guess so man
I feel like we've gifted over the amount
of viewers we have
and you guys were saying that it's not
possible Right
am I still being dumb I might turn on
the light hold on
it's really dark in here
really dark really dark
it got doc out
how's my face like less visible
I'm stalling hold
there we go
okay
it's not much better probably because
I'm wearing a hat all right
thank you it's my mom's carpet
I will not be taking it with me to the
apartment
all right let's do this thing man I
don't think I can do this but let's do
it
let's get all our boys up
hmm
he's pretty weak to roxling
I just did it again like an idiot
come here
that was not worth it
time to move
that's not reaching
gamer
gamer
just run just run
oh he's down
and I said it could I couldn't do it
first try
Logan
God damn
last one I swear you got this one Jake
we got it baby heading out in a few you
all have a good day
fifty dollars fifty dollar super chat
again
last one he swears
hit your head now man I appreciate you
so much thank you dude you're insane you
are insane I appreciate it man thank you
thank you
and then you gifted a great room
membership to Joshua I don't know if you
had a choice in that but thank you dude
I all the support from everybody
Legends
W's in the chat for Logan just going
nuts today and everybody
and we beat radon first try
now is that because here's your three
possible outcomes of why we beat redon
first try chat
one
being a mage is just easy
two
Rock sling is just kind of op right
there
or three I'm just a God I'm a God gamer
and that's why we did it
you take your pick
one two and three
okay I'll take that
the last two
right it was because of Logan and I'm
cheating right I'm cheating
one and two definitely not three metal
why you being mean to me today
stop it
I am nothing but nice to you
I think that was good leveling that was
good levels
plus we can go duplicate
we're done
and then get more
ah hello there
he's sad
um it was a battle marvelously fought
you are well and truly a champion friend
I on the other hand I'm nothing but a
Croc one hit well it took to crack me
and for my insides to come spilling out
after that I
my head like a coward and as such
I can hardly stand to face one such as
you
I am pretty cool
but don't you think I've given up just
yet
as luck would have it there's a
veritable mountain of Warriors bodies
right here Logan
if I can just squeeze this Bunch down
upgraded to a demigod you mighty warrior
again in no time
and you know the bodies found here are
exceedingly all I can say is thank you
dude you could expect it I appreciate
you marry Warriors who fought in the
shattering oh no if you have to do that
every time
I'll grow even stronger
just you wait when next we meet I think
Alexander is the only true character in
the game that is actually your friend
you know what I mean
he's like literally your only real
friend
I think
oh yeah
uh hold on one second I need to answer
something
answering answering answering
okay
you guys like the squishy sounds he's
making
wait was that everything
are exceedingly fine who could expect
any less from the very Warriors who
fought in the shattering the greatest of
all wars what about hoslo just you wait
and see Frank I think is the biggest
[ __ ]
he kind of saves himself
a bit
with uh the jarberg quest
and then you know Bach isn't really a
friend he's just kind of a simp yeah and
I was waiting for you oh what a sick way
to fighting the glory of the Clash is
shared no uh he's always there fan you
after you talk to him initially did you
see that afterwards
falling star right before our eyes
we just didn't go there something about
scale
he was a living legend If Ever I saw one
and the path has now been cleared to
nokra 's fate will be decided let's meet
where the falling star bit the Earth
would you guys see blyde's your friend
too for mistress I'd say so
why it's a friend until he goes nuts
that's not really his fault
you know
I think if he was in full control of
himself he wouldn't try to kill us
and EG
there's more friends
there's more friends yeah he's a good
he's a good boy you're a good boy yeah
okay where can I go and turn in um
radon's great room like where where's
the mausoleum
we already used this one down here
where's another one
there aren't any in Lim grave right
are there any mausoleums in caled
no
no
patches is not your friend
hahaha
yeah there's one in lorenia
um
why am I room not remembering where it
is isn't it like over here
let me let me go try and find it
you can fight blide for fun here and he
won't die right
foreign
frenzy flame Village
right [ __ ]
wait does that one get knocked down
the one over here
I don't know if I've ever knocked that
one down okay the light did not come
or do I have to kill some dudes
I gotta kill some dudes bro
he's a lovable scumbag
he's your favorite NPC in the game
man he's not mine but
each their own there it is
foreign
if I remember right this one does not
have
goals on its feet
foreign
how do you knock this one down
but I gotta kill all the all the bad
boys
[Music]
let's kill all of them
I have to jump on top of it
[Music]
from where
foreign
you look like FaZe Banks I don't I do
not know if that's a compliment
[Music]
[Music]
cameras bro
there's no white stuff on his legs on
this one
foreign
[Music]
can I go that far
oh that one goes extra high
because you gotta go all the way up
there
how do I so you guys are saying I gotta
get them closer gotta kill the enemies
break dude
okay
[Music]
[Music]
where did those just go
oh I just have to wait so I don't have
to kill them
gotcha
there are no skulls on the feet of this
one
oh god
oh okay it's literally coming closer
like that was way closer
[Music]
oh
that's fine
[Music]
see they're up here
[Music]
this game is so [ __ ] cool
foreign
[Music]
all right that was close
I did get thrown off I didn't die though
we're good
okay let's duplicate radon
hey
we also have this one
I already did that
do I just have another one
oh I get it never mind
never mind I'm being dumb
yeah of course there's another one now
we got two just using them for runes
easy 80k
80k
big [ __ ] out here right now
all right
see what that gets us
four levels
dude I just put it into Vigor we'll go
Max 30 and then everything else goes
into in whatever else we need
because our Vigor sucks butt cheeks
it sucks butt cheeks chat
that's what I'm gonna do
we're gonna do that
okay
I have a question
using Rock sling
is beating Ronaldo possible
because she's super against magic but
that's more
that's different
that's physical damage
yes
let's go do that
it's 80. we'll get there we will get to
80. also we can reallocate levels if we
want to after we beat her
pretty much the only way to do it with
the mage build okay
yeah she does not have any Poise Delino
depending on the Walking Mausoleum you
can get three gods of the grafted
remembrances and you don't use Rock
sling against Ronaldo why wouldn't I use
Rock sling against Renault
we agreed on 30. GB
I thought we agreed on 30.
for vigor
and then nothing else
I'd done killed her and haven't even
completed the game
would you guys consider Ronaldo the
easiest demigod not demigod like main
remembrance boss fight
foreign
godric's really easy
I mean he is now
he was pretty easy at first too it did
not take me that many tries
Ronaldo can [ __ ] you up
if you're not careful
into 80 ASAP
okay
well we're gonna level the 30 bigger and
then we will do int
we're only three off of it
fighting a glitch what kind of glitch
was on um godric
what was glitching out
what up Carter yo
oh Stoner to death you know we don't
kill her right
we're fighting a trap set by Ronnie
we're fighting her true power
Renault is [ __ ] batshit insane
oh we gotta kill the dog I just
remembered this the dog might be harder
than Ronaldo
oh right
sorry metal
yeah that was funny you haven't played
since then
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
that's how the first attempt should have
gone
are you into this
go check again seven
metal I also meant you haven't fought
ranala since me you and Cole tried to
fight Ronaldo with the glitch
that's my man
all right let's go beat up Ronnie's mom
and then we'll come back through this
area because I'm pretty sure we can get
a lot of good wizard [ __ ] here
but I just want to beat Ronaldo so that
we're through the area
oh yeah I am Perry hotter
you're goddamn right
I haven't even changed my clothes
oh are we gonna want Ronaldo's hat
and her clothes
no do you like this game Metal
I feel like you don't like Elden ring
all right I'm not fighting this guy
watch this
exactly
as I had it planned out
you're not our moon Chum today
I don't like games anymore I'm not a
gamer I'm just kidding laughs
[Laughter]
I'm sorry I was not expecting
oh
sorry
sorry
I don't know red as long as we want
I don't know who gifted me but thanks
got a lot of gifted today
a lot of gifty vibes
y'all see what I'm looking at right now
y'all see that
there's a kid floating up there
who needs Ronaldo's outfit when he got
death bed Smalls
best helmet in the game what is that
strange
why is there a kid there should there be
a kid there
I bet they put him there just for the
sound
but I don't think he should be in view
oh the panties
that was not the loincloth there was a
kid floating right there
[Music]
this is so [ __ ] weird little Culver
I'll soon yeah we will Alexandra
definitely
fresh and pure
Elden Lord you would reside in Raya
lucaria
I would reside in volcano Manor
I love I love the atmosphere there
reminds me of bloodborne
found sight
okay
is she resistant to the slice
resistance to the slice
foreign
there you are you little [ __ ]
that's right I called a child a [ __ ]
what are you gonna do about it
nice
the crazy blast is her flinging her
children at you by the way
you know
I don't think I've ever gone through
three stages of this
he turns them into gravestones and then
throws them at you
God dang it come on
nice
nice
[Music]
I don't think so Drex
you're not really killing her mom you're
killing of of a trapped
you're killing an illusion of Ronaldo in
this stage right here
first part you're you're hitting her all
that blood on the ground is hers but you
don't kill her
which I don't think she'd be very happy
about either my beloved
I have no fear I will hope I need to
level mind as well yeah
I just want to get to 30 bigger and then
we can focus on mind and int decks
we're three levels away
the follow-up attack Flintstone pebble
mother's Rich Slumber shall not be
disturbed by Thee I see you cast stones
upon my mother
foul trespasser
send word far and wide yeah this this
scene is awesome
it's one of my favorites too
we'll get comment after the fight
granola of the full moon
don't wake Mama witch
forefathers one and all
well Brian thank you for gifting a
membership to Phoenix I appreciate that
thank you very much
thank you thank you
her Dex is insane
[Music]
this is like a whole different fight
as a wizard
of course there's one wolf lover
[Music]
[Music]
foreign Giant
hard to get the timing right
[Music]
can I hit her like this I like that
yep we gotta get radagon's icon too yep
[Music]
I almost died the lag
you dragon
my God
it'll disappear
nice
[Music]
GG no reason
[Music]
let's go
that wasn't that bad we got through that
pretty quick
where's radicon's icon is in
it's in liernia right not leernia
Landell
pretty sure where did he free my
sweetings
come out from whence he hide
yeah should we get her staff
we want to get her staff and her hat
right come out
or will he be gravestones
letter born anew
gravestones
I wish to be born
right above the red wolves Arena
sweet reborn of mine am I thinking of a
different icon yeah I'm thinking of God
for his icon I think you're right
so it is here
you don't need a remembrance for the hat
I don't oh yeah it's just there
be not alarmed
not a fear you're right I would birth
thee as a Sweeting
fair and fine how much int do I need to
use her staff
foreign
if that's what we really want
egg true
egg
60.
that's a lot okay
can I skip her I'm we're skipping this
all this
she talks a lot
good become we'll go get the radagons
icon too and we'll go get uh
comment is there like we'll get
everything
seed power remembrance
okay we'll get there eventually but
should I buy this
staff is not worth it I'm getting
from a few people in chat it doesn't
seem that good
let's be
it boosts full moon sorcery
yeah no we we should duplicate it first
right
yeah
we should duplicate it where where are
other uh
mausoleums aren't they like over here
yes
Lou sat staff
isn't loose at
by Millicent and Caleb
so you're saying we should get the Dark
Moon and not the staff
we can just get her clothes normal
we need to Let's duplicate this first
let's focus on that
let's duplicate
okay
laggy laggy here
Ronnie's moon is better
yeah that's way late though
we can get that later right yeah
probably
I'm trying to Skyrim it and I don't need
to
just go like this
okay are these ones weird
I gotta I gotta jump on them from a
certain direction or something
out
oh yeah they jump that's right
foreign
Godwin staff and comma is their spell
staff
isn't that just the death staff
do I jump at it from over here Chad
let me get this first
amazing scaling principal desktop
okay
I remember I've had that before but how
how do you get it
I just gotta jump
there's
oh wait this one does have things on its
feet
right
it just jumps in the air
makes it a little harder
foreign
why are these ones so aggressive
compared to the others
oh all right we're good
[Music]
let's go
okay
he's doing burpees
thanks
okay
it's for lesser remembrances
how do we figure that how do how do you
know that
huh
what
you mean like Regal
stuff like that
a bell
oh my God what about that one
I do with that one
you have to have a belt [ __ ]
I am learning so many things from you
today
I have to buy the remembrance item first
well I'm knocking him down anyway
also they don't have a bell is that how
you know
because they don't have a bell
are these just like less important
demigods
wow
feels bad for these guys I guess huh
if they don't have a bell they can only
do certain remembrances gotcha
like assil or the deer God
okay so that one won't work either well
at least we have them down
I guess that makes sense so you don't
like
over do it
the same I did not know that
okay
let's go buy
her hat
if it's Nobel it's no demigod
remembrance right okay I wonder why
they're remembered then
you know
I wonder why they're chosen for that
equipment of the Champions so we're
buying this hat right
what about the rest of her clothes
is it just the Hat
increa it literally increases
intelligence
yeah it's the Hat
okay
oh
Harry hotter is looking good
real good
it works
okay
so that's something do I have like
better
you know this oh I haven't gotten any
armor
two fingers looking thick oh okey-dokey
let's go get radicon's icon yep let's go
through this area
um
which is
not there close classroom debate
I gotta go around that's right
banana
banana power banana power
I don't know why I thought I could use
torrent
[Music]
not over here is it
yes
don't say I'd be in a Hufflepuff
that's the lames
lame team
LOL
it's on the other side
total Hufflepuff
you guys are mean
I think I look cool
thanks Vance I'm glad you like it okay
we got the icon
Norton's spell casting time
that's big
that's good okay
big dick swinging currently
hey put it out
I'm a Slytherin emboldened by the flame
of ambition
is there anything else I need here chat
trying to remember
I know we can go on the rooftops and
stuff where where do I get Comet
we can also go to caled and go to that
secret area
bookcase
got sometimes I just have to really
remember
Stalin questline
I mean that's later
gotta scroll
we can give that to selling
yeah we killed tops I got paid to kill
tops all right chat
and then it's like
a secret spot around here right three
[Music]
late
um I appreciate that Trey thank you
thank you for the 20 Super Chat get some
W's
Mr falconzy
owl
oh was it behind there
[Music]
ow
oh [ __ ]
I'm excited for the new apartment though
it's really nice
it's in a good area
it's gonna be good
I move in January 14th
ah thank you
that's the smithing Stone
green is lilies
my game froze okay
is that it
oh [ __ ] am I dead
how do I get out of here
you can go up from there
oh
thank you
and that did not look like a path at all
increases intelligence to the detriment
of HP
I'm keeping this
hi Deva
Deva
okay
now what
why am I not remembering where comet is
I feel like common Azure is not here
it's wait it's right outside dog room
yeah yeah
foreign
[Music]
foreign
bookcase upstairs
yeah the memberships have been [ __ ]
crazy today
oh
I don't think I've ever looked at this
closely
it's a wicked painting over Hollow there
we go
that's big
comment big
yeah not common dessert but that that
attack is quite good
okay
cool
oh fathers one and all
Brian gifting another membership thank
you dude
why can't I pick up this statue and use
it
Brian's gifted a lot of members too
today thank you very much
it's Baby Comet but it's a start it's
still really good
Azure staff is here where
still go up there
this one up the ladder
flip it upside down
can't yet
there's all kinds of hidden areas
oh
what the [ __ ] man
do I go down this little hole
foreign
how have I just not done these things
like you guys are showing me new [ __ ]
all day this is crazy
that's like the I've never seen this
ever
[Music]
I think I'm bad at exploring
Ravens well Talisman what does that do
oh
God's helped me through the lengthy hot
whoa
yo
what
[Music]
what happened
yeah I just got put in Ravenclaw man
okay you guys said there was a staff
here
is there no staff
oh
it's in a church
not there but in Raya Lucario
I gotta climb the rooftops
going to the rooftops baby
I kind of figured this is where we'd get
all our [ __ ]
you know
let me trade out
should I trade that out
well now I can't
now I can't use that
poop
all right we're done with vigor we have
finished it
now
it's very out of the way really
I'm not even using this to be honest
just one hand this
bunny sneeze
do you believe in magic
foreign
not really okay
we said staff is in the town of sorcery
as well as Knight comet
oh I should have attached my new comment
keep forgetting
hmm
[Music]
down for puppets I'll do my best
ah
awesome excellent
yeah
[Laughter]
there we go whoa
the heck is that
okay you can't reach
okay
it increased in speed
wizard duel
oh [ __ ] dick
whoever animated that
get off crack
uh your vods helped me through lengthy
Hospital stay over Christmas
Rock Buck brain surgery so thank you and
sorry for the death
oh I'm I forgot I was reading that I'm
sorry bungalus that is I'm happy to help
in any way man I'm really sorry about
that
um hopefully he's getting better
recovering as as well as you can
um
best of luck to you man that [ __ ]
sucks
but I'm happy I can help and
in any way
I can really explored man I'm I guess
I'm bad at exploring
I've like I think I've done this area
once
just like never came back
we're here
hovering well
watching your Elder and runs I'm a VOD
catcher in the UK so I mean hey I
appreciate you watching them man
you're here live
it's a bonus
there we go
my day's been good Big D how about you
hey
you only do Mage builds see this is my
first mage build I've done I'm always
big dick sword
no I've no this is my first one so it's
fun though I'm having fun it's very
different
oh [ __ ]
okay oh fathers
[Music]
oh Logan's back oh
Logan gifting two memberships
after like five billion earlier
thank you man
I appreciate you thank you very much
foreign
I swear man yeah okay
yeah okay bro
I'm kidding I'm kidding
did that other one just fall
yep
these are open
is that it right there do I drop right
here
this has got to be important
that
was for tops
pops is dead
bombs whatever the [ __ ]
that guy took all the magic away and to
smacked me with his [ __ ] book
for the page
okay
this
is shattering Crystal good
gotta be good to have who the [ __ ] was
that over there
Little Wizard crab
okay
that seems good what does that do
greatly increases intelligence at the
detriment of HP and stamina is that
really good
foreign
this guy does not look like a homie
at all chat
we just out here big dick in it you know
what I mean
whoa
chat
I've lit I've never seen this before
it's just like down below
that staff looks sick
I can't even use it
52 int
I want to see what it looks like
damn son
that's pretty cool
yeah this is the best one we have right
now
I thought you played this game over a
billion times yeah I have it's just
insane how many different things there
are dude like I've never really explored
Raya Lucario before I haven't had a
reason to
I haven't made a video on it so
I mean this has given me a lot of ideas
dude
I just need to stream more I guess
you can equip it in your offhand and
gain a buff
really like I'll still get the buff
like just have it there
what buff do I get
crazy man
80 inch all right we're going all in now
it we're doing it we got the 30 vigor
uses 50 more FP per spell but they gain
a buff and faster cast time
oh to damage okay
speed buff okay
it's faster
I can feel it
literally faster dude let's go okay is
that everything we needed in this area
peace
flip it in your off hand and gain a buff
yeah yeah
okay
we beat redone
I can use her uh should we go get the
the Moon spell
okay we've gone through Hogwarts that's
crazy man dude
can't believe it
should we get her Moon
just to have
and we can also duplicate this even
after I use it right
I mean I guess I can get this later
get this later
so I don't need it right now
but if I use this I can also duplicate
it later right
yes
Logan
continuing the gift members like crazy
bro
thank you man
I you're support today has been kind of
unbelievable so I I really appreciate it
dude
three more we're almost at 200 members
and we started the day at like 75.
that is crazy to me you want the staff
as well why do we need all these staffs
chat like aren't we gonna pick one and
keep it
but W's in the chat for Logan yet again
bro this guy's just going crazy today
probably Logan Tim could could be some
others too for sure
you can thank you
I'm gonna use it for for Rooney voice
doesn't give you that many
foreign
level let's go
let's go
W's Logan
why would you need four they give you
different boosts so like do I have to
hold it or can it just be in my
inventory and I've got it
or do I have to hold it out like this
and then I get the buff
because if I have like you know I could
put snaps in every one of these and I'd
get a buff from each one
you can dual wield must hold it you can
dual wield stay for more effects or to
cast over and over
wow
interesting do I want to do that though
not really
personally
hmm
rock and roll coaster of magic user I
mean you got you guys seem to know like
you're gonna know a lot more to me about
having a
this type of thing
a sorcery build
I just had my stream playing on my phone
or I have no idea how long
no clue
use two staves like a true Mage I guess
I don't know what it means to be a midge
I guess I don't know what it means
all right what what should I do
trying to think
can I finish bia's thing here
after level 50 meteorite staff will
become useless okay
now
come closer
hold it then change for Ronnie's staff
cast dark move then change the death
Prince and nuke thanks
okay I think I get what you you mean
very warm for the spell I'm using I
switch it up right
should I ask about Roger
that makes sense
of great mental fortitude it anchors his
will
despite his Grievous wounds you truly
are a champion to Dear Russia
and myself too
a tater I wasn't listening to that [ __ ]
potato made us a wheel chat
it was his idea
Annie made a wheel
for uh the the wheel of level run that
we're gonna do
fine how can I do this
it's like if I just do this
sorry I'm I'm thinking of this already
and I shouldn't be
do that
and then
I can put it on screen like this I think
everybody hold
yep there it is
and I can go like this
aha
how's that working for everybody okay
and then every time we want to use it we
pop it up on screen and I can show the
chat
thank you for making that potato
and then let's see if it spins for you
like on screen
it should
endurance
cool all right nice we'll use that for
when we're doing that sweet thank you
man
that's big
we're ready to go nice
thanks man also if if you're a new
member because we've gotten a lot of new
members today make sure you join the
members only Discord go to the community
tab of this stream of this Channel and
you should be able to see it you'll get
a link to it
we have a normal Discord
for the normies
Mike could you please find do you think
morgant needs a buff wolf and return it
to them hi Venom
gave it to me
thing
it must have a special oh really Matt
okay
for the original owner to have it back
you're going to need a scepter so you
can upgrade
huh
I have no idea what it means to be a
wizard
you're all teaching me
the way
of Perry hotter
[Music]
okay
but we need to
can I talk to Roger about this now
my brain's all over the place right now
always good to see you safe so
what do you need
maybe I should tell you you should tell
me everything I feel I'm on the
precipice of falling into a deep
fathomless Slumber kind of like Ronnie
even inkling it could spell trouble for
you somehow so I just wanted to get the
apology out of the way beforehand since
you're so scary and all
all right
did he just call me scary
I'm not scary I'm gonna go ahead and
grab the pebble well let me make sure I
I got the Spells I want
you missed a lot you're in a meeting
Lots happen
a lot okay
let's just put everything out on the
table
we're using Rock sling obviously we've
got Comet but we can't use it yet until
we get to 52. so let's just use
Pebble [ __ ] it
um Terra Magica
Bay lanx
that great bow is sick
um and then we gotta use slicer so we we
kind of already had everything we want
oh we should give selling the Scrolls
and then get new ones yep good call
fantastic call Young One
use the buff I don't know how to use the
buff I don't know what that means I I
don't know what you're saying
I'm not in a fight either I don't I
don't know what the buff does
my Apprentice shall we commence the
lesson
give scroll
is that a scroll
takes me back to my Academy days very
well okay where do I get that night
comment sorcery with which I'm not
entirely unfamiliar I'll be sure to
incorporate it into one of your lessons
never lose that inquisitive Spirit my
Apprentice all right okay you guys
really like night comment huh is that a
scroll
takes me back to my Academy days very
well
this is sorcery with which I'm not
entirely unfamiliar I think it'll always
go to somebody who you can buy it from
lessons
never lose that inquisitive Spirit my
Apprentice
okay
glintstone Comet Shard Flintstone stars
star shower
Crystal barrage
are any of these worth getting
I'm kind of blocking everything that's
my bad but
great Flintstones yard glintstone Comet
Shard that looks really good
[Music]
and Then star shower looks cool too
star showers meta
I'm gonna get it I think I I like it so
I'm gonna get it
I like it so it's mine
okay
spell
replace this one with
oh
am I dumb where did it go okay it's
right there I couldn't see it
super good tracking okay
let me test it
[Music]
let's go beat up something
that's pretty good
that's really good
oh okay okay
a lot of FP though yeah
FP kind of gets nuked
okay
cool
that is what the plants shoot that's
true
doggy
okay
can we go to that spot in caled
the
like kind of hidden area
the with the fake door
[Music]
it's kind of slow for a non-opener that
sound yeah maybe maybe
we can't go to the town yet
that's like way later
no
okay
it's like over here right
wait do I have to do this with a quest
line
for it to open
that guy's kind of scary holy [ __ ]
you're scared
he's a big wizard
big wizard
foreign
dude that one is awesome
God dang it
thank you
okay
let's
Cannon of Hyma that's what that's called
people running through with baldigan's
blessing
no it's not that hard to miss
a lot of people just totally forget
about it yes
it's also not that big of a deal
I think a lot of people went through the
entire game with it yes
big wizard run I'm trying to be a big
wizard I'm trying my best
I don't know what that was but it was
glowing scary
foreign
I need a key don't I you're right is
there like uh there's like really no
point in me going this far yeah
I get the key from selling
oh [ __ ] you
[Music]
reach
no Lancer I really don't have one yet
sorry
you guys are getting nitpicky with me
it's my playthrough not yours
don't know if that triggers you to give
it to her I don't think it does it
either I don't remember exactly what
triggers it
is it talking to that guy in by
you know the Dead
dude
um by volcano Manor
ish area
it's so hard to describe every area in
this game
okay Thompson's dead
so yeah
holy Skyline
let's go talk to Millicent
since she's here
favorite spell definitely Rock sling
definitely
thanks bigger Z
you gotta find Azure volcano Manor I'm
pretty sure that's what triggers it
100 percent
we also have to save selling
it's not
fewer wise you will leave immediately My
Flesh rides with Scarlet trot
not to be meddled with by man
right if you are wise you will leave
immediately My Flesh rides with Scarlet
trot
all right okay
yeah here's what I'm thinking right now
I gotta get off in a bit anyway
uh
it's not listen to millicentious
be a dude this year
I think tomorrow
we're going to start the wheel of level
run
and I'm gonna stream that the entire day
that's kind of my plan that I have in my
head
let's stream it all day tomorrow
the whole day we'll be doing that run
and I'll try and complete the run in one
day
so big big stream on the brain tomorrow
okay and then whenever we finish that
we'll pick this back up
um so I think I should like probably
stop streaming for now to get ready for
tomorrow you know what I mean
we streamed like four and a half
yesterday
so I'm probably gonna get on
earlier than today
tomorrow so probably like nine maybe 8
30 a.m CST tomorrow and we will go
the entire day until we beat the game
with that run because we hit the
Milestone today which is insane
the support today from literally so many
people kind of blew my mind and put me
in a slight State of shock for about 30
to 45 minutes so
thank you guys for real from the bottom
of my heart like that support today was
[ __ ] mind-blowing for YouTube
I don't think I've ever really seen that
to be honest
um
so we'll be back tomorrow we're gonna
we'll stream the entire day tomorrow so
like if you're on YouTube tomorrow I'm
probably streaming okay
um we'll do the wheel of level run
um we'll explain that all tomorrow if
you don't know what it is it'll be fun
it's gonna be super fun I'm actually
really looking forward to that
um if you're a new member please make
sure to join the Discord go to the
community Tab and you'll get a link to
the members only Discord
don't forget to do that
um
thank you that's I don't know what else
to say man
um everything's Linked In the
description if you're curious about
anything go check all that stuff out
um if you guys didn't know this too I
also stream on Twitch a little bit
um I don't really promote it here on
YouTube that much but
follow my twitch it's the same name as
here AGT Jake if you're on twitchever I
just like kind of chill out and play
rocket league on there
um to like music that I like and that's
it we we kind of just hang out there and
talk about anything and and the YouTube
is like my main streaming platform but
if you want to just hang out on Twitch
sometime then come over there I don't do
it all I don't stream on there that
often but I'd recommend if you like
twitch
go follow me on there as well um
we'll be back all day here on YouTube
tomorrow
so I'm out of here again appreciate you
guys from the bottom of my heart dude
today was insane I can't believe it
um
and we'll be back man so thank you all
again have a great rest of your day
and uh
I'll see you tomorrow
thanks again everyone
peace out dude